why aren't Americans buying more when a
greater number are being employed that
is a puzzle for many economists and the
Fed and what I want to sort out with our
neck with our next guest former Fed
Chairman Alan Greenspan
chairman Greenspan thank you so much for
joining me this morning we're hoping you
can solve some of this mystery as to why
we're adding jobs and it looks great but
we're not spending what's going on here
well it's unfortunately very simple but
not a good story it's turning out that
we're using more and more people at the
margin to produce less and less
productivity which is output for
man-hours and conventionally measure it
is running at a very low rate of
increase and that's the critical
variable in the economy over both the
short term and the long term
so what we're confronted with right now
is a very serious problem caused by the
fact that capital investment has been
falling far short of the requirements
necessary to keep the capital stock
growing and therefore productivity it's
not working so how do we reverse that
what what exactly is behind that
chairman well on many occasions
indicated that the best way to
understand this is to track it backwards
this there's a very tight relationship
between the stock of non-residential
capital private stock and output per an
hour hour they move together parallel
and on all the time for very good
reasons but that capital stock requires
capital investment and capital
investment in turn is being crowded out
by very substantial increase in
government expenditures basically in
entitlements because both parties both
the Republicans and the Democrats don't
want to talk about it largely because it
is considered the third rail American
politics you touch it and you lose well
so that makes perfect sense so so it
might come down to cutting some costs
right to cost controls chairman top of
your list I know you've mentioned
entitlement spending you know you've got
Medicare Social Security the number one
thing that you think we need to cut our
cost on is what well the the basic issue
is the entitlements and the reason it's
a problem is that people put money in of
their own funds and the employers funds
plus interest and that's what they
perceive that they get back and
therefore they are entitled to it
because it's their money right the only
problem is that's not what we're doing
we're not creating enough funding for
the Social Security trust funds and the
same thing goes from it for Medicare
Part A and we're not funding this and so
long as we're not funding this we are
dollar for dollar crowding out capital
investment dr. Greenspan you know some
look at these numbers though I mean not
just jobs but but the the lack of
productivity as you just pointed out
also the spending declines that we are
seeing but also the strength of the
dollar as perhaps delaying the Fed
policy on raising interest rates I know
you don't speculate you don't want to
interfere on Janet yellen's job but all
of those factors combined do they
foreshadow perhaps a longer wait on
moving on monetary policy
well you're merely repeating what is
probably going on in the internal
discussions of the Federal Open Market
Committee
and I won't comment on that okay
understood the the higher dollar though
dr. Greenspan is that going to have or
do you believe it's going to keep a lid
on inflation what do you mean it's
productivity or what's going to keep
them in the you at the higher US dollar
okay so we just talked about how the
higher US dollar should be reducing
import costs for many companies it's not
so far but if it does is that going to
help alleviate some of the inflationary
pressures and possibly the need the need
again not to forecast raising interest
rates or not but the need to tighten
yeah I know there's no question a
stronger dollar tends to suppress the
general domestic price level but the
problem here is we're not quite certain
where the problem on the exchange rate
comes from whether it's a strong US
economy which is a questionable issue or
a weak rest of the world which is a
little bit more credible you remember
with exchange rates in a global economy
or a zero-sum game if the dollar goes up
something else there goes down and what
we're seeing is a significant weakening
obviously in the euro we're seeing it in
the narubu we're seeing it in the one so
I mean it's a it's a very very complex
problem of international trade and
international capital flows and it's not
altogether clear that the US can readily
make major changes in the dollars
exchange rate because it's such a
critical currency that the types of
actions that we would have to take
probably outside the realm of where we
think it's good policy Chairman I know
that oil is something that you have been
watching very closely you say it's
extremely important for us to be
watching what happens to oil you believe
we still haven't hit rock bottom here
right
that's that's correct ready if you look
at the data as you just pointed out our
major domestic facility for storage is
in Cushing Oklahoma which is a delivery
point for West Texas Intermediate crude
contracts we're probably at the point
now where at the current rate of fill
we're gonna run out of room in Cushing
by next month and then the question is
where does the crude go because
everyone's forecast as to what was going
to happen when the prices collapsed was
a sharp curtailment in shale oil
production that has not happened the
weekly figures which are produced by the
Energy Information Agency through March
the 6th show a continued rise in
domestic crude production and it has got
no place to go because we can't legally
export the way we would most products we
can do a little exporting to Canada but
essentially we're bottling up a huge
amount of crude oil in the United States
so that the west texas intermediate
intermediate price is running $10 a
barrel under Brent crude which is the
global price and that take basically
means that we are creating great
abnormalities in the system and unless
and until we find a way to get out of
this dilemma prices will continue to
ease because there's no place for that
oil to go except into the markets and
spot crews are especially vulnerable
because we so call contango
is a very high level and that implies
that there's a very very significant
instead of pressures on the spot price
dr. Greenspan
what about this theory though I mean it
when it seems inevitable we're gonna see
this huge oversupply and oil prices come
down even more
isn't that eventually going to hit us
oil production it might be a very sharp
crash in the number of rigs that that
get closed down but eventually the
markets will adjust well remember the
rigs that have been closing down have
not been affecting the capacity to
produce crude yet and the reason is that
most of them are the ones which are not
multiple well related you're getting the
inefficient rings shutting down but the
capacity to basically build a Kapoor
oil expansion remains there and frankly
I had expected it to turn down or ease
number of weeks ago and these numbers
keep rising now it is perfectly credible
that because the cost of crude
especially for I should say for shale
crude which is more expensive than
standard old-fashioned crude those
numbers are high or you know fifty five
sixty five dollars a barrel there is
some Eagle Ford Shale which is going
under 50 dollars a death barrel but
there's not much room under there before
cash flow turns negative at that point
they shut down and it could be quite the
brunt I might point out right that's
right it could it could it could be very
abrupt and then chairman Greenspan if
nothing is done here short of let's say
a lift of our export ban on crude what
could we expect from OPEC well I think
that OPEC is no longer the price leader
I wrote a long editorial op-ed piece
last week or so in which I pointed out
that essentially what's happening is
that because of the ad
laughter shell which is a very much more
flexible type of facility to expand and
contract crude that the marginal global
price making mechanism has moved to the
United States away from OPEC and I think
that that's going to continue unless and
until prices fall below the costs of
crude production from shale which is
very significantly above where for
example the Saudi crews there's some
crowd there are some Saudi crews which
can be lifted at less than a dollar a
barrel in the go air fields and the huge
glare field in Saudi Arabia we're lucky
if we can get $40 yeah no that's a
that's a great point it's incredible and
it sort of brings to light just how
complicated the situation is dr.
Greenspan thank you so much for joining
us this morning the former Federal
Reserve Chairman Alan Greenspan